welcome to the first ever cringe mess
we're gonna have so much fun today oh
boy blow it up again
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh jingle bells jingle bells jingle all
the way oh what fun it
right in the one-horse open sleigh
jingle bells jingle bells jingle all the
way
Oh
horse open sleigh
[Music]
the
Oh
[Music]
what is your problem sorry that's your
problem
good he's my problem
Oh dad never dad no but I mess this up
oh there we go
[Applause]
oh can we get a million likes on this
video
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
do you wanna build a snowman
yes the other one go oh no are we above
run the runs way yeah that is terrifying
[Applause]
it's cooking time
Christmas dinner cooking competition
[Applause]
what are you guys gonna cook for us
today
a wreath of weenies it's a weenie
alright next what else are you gonna
make Christmas candle salad that is
penises moving on Tim's the mom a banana
what do we got we're gonna make a turkey
cake that's very clever that's very nice
I can't wait to button my teeth into
that come I will now try this please
it's good how was that yes sure yes oh
[Music]
don't do it man all right ah belching is
considered a sign of respect
thank you very much I have provided you
with spoons in the form of these peppers
wash pepper I'm aware Richard barbarians
would never eat with a mixing spoon
y'all part of me I may not be an expert
so how would you recommend Oh allow me
to carve the turkey for you yeah is me
delectable delectable what are while we
wait for mark to cut that no no I'm done
I'm done
okay I was Megan hi donations but okay
no no no those can wait these sample the
tacky
mmm did you put any sweets in the back
end yeah if I did if you see inside
there are sweets why isn't this we
decided to UM lighten up for you have
you got some powdered sugar for you just
like you asked that's a lot of salt it's
gonna be hard don't like that one then
yeah cause they told us about mayonnaise
on we did it oh don't get sick don't get
sick ears Felix did I hear you correctly
saying your mouth is a little dry please
a bottle of water from the Alps oh I
mean we used it out of ice myself please
very well well look away this terrible
foul Jane there's not even a competition
the winners are what's your name again
beautifly VG bye
thank I'm amazing you know it used to
use you just mmm this is garbage
three person to one it's wrapped way
down so we use one hand and passing a
little one-handed wrapping everybody
like that and meanwhile so me and Edgar
it's I'm just gonna just sit here wait
look at what my backers got good that is
amazing thanks so much this is actually
been a good back yeah I think you need
to focus I'm sorry for distracting you
that's clearly not good enough you are a
fair and impartial judge who is also
extremely handsome might I add all right
yeah it looks like the wrongs are doing
an excellent job over well well you know
what they say it has an earache I'm
drooling everywhere okay I will be
judging on style Irishness Irish Oh
oz will be very I'm fluffy here the Rams
win bring Smith pictionary time I don't
know why I did like that inside the
claws coming down a pipe Santa Claus
trip teasing naked Santa sad belly Santa
wait you wait you said something a
minute ago that sounded like strip
teasing Santa Paul dancing Santa yes
pole dancing Santa technically I said it
quicker
oh hell yeah turn turn oh oh
[Music]
with you okay this is a really nice
that's my Irish dance I am the one now
added oh I got the biggest love
alright lacks a Christmas tree into part
of your body excuse what what this is
the forfeit wax a Christmas tree into
part of your body this is gonna be
painful it will be as painful I wax my
legs twice by now well have food if I
ever done it that was my best okay here
we go
granny's gonna hurt I'm sorry by the way
I don't want it do it do it just do it
oh my god oh oh I got you oh wow two
more three more Jesus quotes good what
happened no I'm out of here guys see you
later
here's the gun see you next time all
right except do ready three two one ah
yeah allowed the group to wrap you up
like a present example paper and bow you
must keep as much of the wrapping on as
possible until the next cracker I hate
my life
we hate you too we wish you a Merry
Christmas we wish you a Merry Christmas
we wish you
if I got that on Christmas Day I would
be very disappointing three two one
trakula whoa crack their silent disco
night what does that mean it means the
following we want you to perform a
one-minute interpretive dance expressing
the meaning of Christmas no music
one minute costume required oh do we
have a cost we have a costume ever
oh I know what kind of costume this is
can you take these yes thank you okay uh
everybody
make sure you own a everybody make
Perdition gum okay this is the worst
I've seen so far what is happening I
never thought I'd be turned on by a
snowman 3 2 1 go oh it almost hurts
it's called Santa's beard ha ha ha I
take pride in everything I do
oh I'm feeling it ha ha ha no it's the
hot sauce ok ok thank god damn it they
sucked bad tuna you win a glitter tatoo
makeover administered by the group keep
everything on until the end of the next
crack you get to do it
this is purnsley anyway you want this is
you can't find this anywhere should we
prize that's gonna have something around
oh really home
oh I'm gonna have we're gonna bedazzle
you I feel she's gathering Oh in the
nose please yeah I've got like couple
horns coming actually Oh golly please
don't do those Asajj that right down the
tip oh yeah it looks like a beauty mark
can someone take to get her away from
Felix yeah we just need to get rid of
that together Emma
it's like dealing with a four-year-old
and this is this is your best look so
amazing so happy I was here you guys
this is permanent three two one oh this
one's called the eggnog
[Music]
well I woulda lost again anyway we're
getting here let's say you have it
édouard manet own hands one hand ah does
that work
alright you've seen Edward Scissorhands
well now Marik Maradona colony pan under
Tony this requires some fine muscle
skills yeah oh come on no no it's gotta
be feel good yeah okay he has to put on
makeup in the side of his favorite
beauty vlogger and then he has to wear
that makeup until the next crack oh
that's a massive wall my favorite
beautiful is your favorite beautiful oh
my god I have some of me I don't know
where to pick I I wasn't gonna say
anything but I'm launching my new
channel it's called booty booty
beauty beauty beauty beauty by beauty
beauty by okay alright I know what the
temp okay oh my goodness I don't need to
know what this stuff actually is know
what Oh God
you're a wizard having close your eyes
Thank You Sheila
oh you look diving to God you say that
oh hang on what is that she's really
worried done we've done we got upset no
I'm pretty where's that a mascara go now
how do I look you look great man oh I
think we did a good job
how long do I have to keep this up all
the next crackers everyone punched jack
in the face donation $50 or move from
who edge I hate Jack 24 Oh last 23 good
lord
it's even worse than that face you got I
let my buddy the show you can we get
that I saw my father oh my god hello
okay oh how we're trying to get their
name I can this can what can they scam
don't it hey like a great dodge ball and
I like it
oh hey how you doing yeah zoom in on my
face donate
here we go Oh what is my life I don't
know I'm looking at this and so are you
stop stop stop stop
and the witness doc Klappa Klappa Taha
anything anything well we've only got 12
okay
there's one here behind three four five
six seven eight nine 10 11 12 13
whatever
no but look the line would go no no I
but what beautiful Joe is exactly like
this Dean dates Oh
Nessus no no no judge judge Owen doesn't
mind you may cut judge judge judge yes
judge over here I think we need to get
mark a drink okay darker studio we just
got a donation of $500 loving the stream
great cost
glad I could contribute thank you for
contributing uh even though I love
watching Jack could he have a cream pie
to the face just do it
I don't want to do it you know what i
forfeit you yes kitty hey I don't like
you I never liked you I I mean I do like
you oh I want Jack to kiss PJ on the
cheek with mock crying in the background
I think someone wants to print screen' a
little something here so so you should
cry in the background of me kissing PJ
on the cheek
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much for your donation on
an open fire Jack Frost nipping at your
nose Yuletide Carol some song by the
fire better does he love URI
Jay tell me I'm Edgar hey Edgar
all right what do you wanna come over
here okay I appreciate what you're doing
it all right you have 20 minutes to
create the most incredible gingerbread
doghouse possible for Edgar you see this
cardboard that's what you got to work
with almost like you've done this before
it's tensor stencil put this down here
that was real staples this whole time
are you kidding me get out of the way
are you kidding Oh
how long has there been stapled yeah
there's there's crackers I'm your loo
with God Wow okay did you ever know that
you
I'm my stomach hurts
we ain't hot sauce it's the only hot
sauce on a live string five seconds left
five four three two one zero
fa cringe my way this is rule they said
which one will Edgar enter okay the one
Edgar enters well win
that's a nice strawberry liqueur first
of all let's say just all through them
let's go through what you guys built
first we have a nice big e on the front
and his favorite color green
wait we know he isn't colorblind where
are your new gonna know if Felix can fit
inside you'll get a bonus point okay
sure sure okay thanks I don't let Jack
hold me now okay here we go
Wow and you get Felix this is really
cozy thank you
Wow the games room is in here to the
right yeah yep
wow they prepared Edgar's favorite game
but sniffing puns and here we go it keep
going keep going keep going yeah I love
it you know Chuck even if i watch how
much this erect the rent free back up
for you and Edgar free yep very roomy
hey yeah and he's in yes miss feeling oh
my god Alex he's being burst
ha ha ha oh it's a Christmas miracle
[Music]
look at that Edgar good Eddie anymore
head girl away laughter boy
[Applause]
in front of its face acres and acres in
back Jesus Christ this is it hey hey
where's it save it where is it saving oh
don't worry
I think we're told that you were gonna
do a forfeit a challenge for tomorrow's
cringe miss cuz we're gonna be here
tomorrow as well I'm going to eat sushi
tomorrow
what wow that's a joke how are you sure
oh I promise you I don't believe this
I go go with my hair jelly is here I'm
going jelly which one did you think was
better I I wasn't watching Oh God bye
how about you giving some words of
encouragement then how about that
make sure you donate cuz it's great you
heard it here first make sure you donate
because it's great jelly
20 weeks teen everyone jelly everybody
oh no no hey it's markup I do it sushi
go dad
d I really give just [ __ ] with us he's
like hey I shall fake reaction you know
you are caning it son
hey what are here I eat sushi
hey like belt it out a Christmas carol
or anything
[Applause]
Oh
how much hot sauce did we drink oh my
god drunk dance there for a minute
this secret saying whoa we all went out
and bought gifts for each other not all
of us maybe I didn't buy one again bring
in the gift maybe you'll see why and you
will feel bad what could it be
open it No I hope you don't already have
one of these
No Oh Oh what is it Janet Aveda he
mailed himself I know might have to be
on this oh my god hey Big Daddy we all
Danny DeVito everybody takers from my
office
don't ask questions if what I have if
it's the one from well Danny DeVito how
do you make it here this one says to
Jack from Santa and I'm gonna guess this
is PJ by the way that's a good cat mean
did I don't give you enough clothes I'm
gonna guess that this is Ella nice it's
a desktop browser
bleh yeah you killer yeah it was me yeah
it was Whitney haha oh I know and people
said no don't we moon get faster Oh
deserves a gimme damn it princess he
windows a princess
oh yes you are a beautiful King thank
you bad right you're welcome
when they pulled around by a short walk
home by just wanted to really you know
get a good look at her
do we have a sister she wants Danny
DeVito so oh [ __ ] oh jeez oh all right
okay oh my god that was not worth the
cardboard cut I just got on my phone
ever
why don't you play your stupid drums and
just incredible a hipster beard thank
you very much I'm not gonna good it up
now I can have a beard just like you I
thought about you yes a male I form for
really faces well Oh dad where'd he go
I'm jacksepticeye Brett cheese okay last
present last present why don't I get
what I want earth I got a remote control
I know I know
cold I know
colqhoun there's a total of four coal
inside my stocking yours does not win
it's good I do not win oh oh
so mine is really heavy what about if
what I got just illogical this is new
what if there's a record I got eight
wait Jack has nothing in my 4-h I do not
have what is this hidden puffle did that
we're just duck though toughen my fing
that's in part I did not lose that much
I was wrong I wonder who did it I have
no idea on my side we hit our goal we
are technically now at 1.3 million
dollars for
yeah
[Applause]
46 seconds are the Builder melinda gates
foundation donation of a million dollars
now you really [ __ ] open down the water
oh don't you want our kid doing pretty
oh I'm not your mum the thing is I've
smelled this everyone in the room is
gonna want to leave real fast
I've heard my god that we've only got
four minutes left I love how the can is
bloated yeah that's not a good why is it
rusted - it's illegal open this is
Airport it's it's considered a Terrorism
Act I got my eyes Oh Oh No Oh
seal has been broken oh no dude what
about it
nothing yeah can I continue oh my god
I'm not there yet oh oh ha that is
putrid quite pungent
oh my god stank I can do it I'll do it
oh my god oh my god aah oh oh what's
that that's my mom that would be oh my
god oh jeez all right it is a bad idea
yeah even the cat informative but it is
everybody this has been the first cringe
miss ever thanks thank you guys a milli
of million three hundred thousand times
and everyone who don't know that thanks
to YouTube thanks to the Bill and
Melinda Gates and Melinda Gates
Foundation Jesus cry I'm tired thanks to
red I'm so glad we were able to support
this charity the fact that we raised a
million three hundred thousand dollars
is insane
it really is I'm about to vomit so I'm
over it I'm over it
I bet my indifference but uh that's Lucy
incisions been amazing you guys are the
best
twenty sixty let's never do this again
never then I watch
you